I was a nice lift back there  you got a lot to learn  you stick with me and I'll teach you a  few things no offense but I don't even  know you my friends call me Sully  Nathan Drake  mr. Sullivan and mr. Drake could you  tell me what's so special about that  ring if the lines in my fin inscribed  with Sir Francis Drake's motor greatness  from small beginnings  just what is it you're after  it's just a little historical research  Oh tell me you're buying internal that  supernatural nonsense  if you love all this as much as I  now  these guys are playing for keeps  he would go to the ends of the earth for  meat  we jump just don't ask shall we  you get a funnel  but that's not  and this  we don't get to choose how we started  this life and  I real greatness  it's what you do with the hand it dealt  you're a crook right yeah what do you  want from me I see great things in our  future kidding great things  you  closed a song